brandon and julia
this is your first 90 day run we are now
two episodes in
how are you feeling
um i feel jealous why
because more girl right brandon
oh that's a good thing for you brandon
i i know i guess i mean i'm happy that
when i got so
i don't need a great answer great answer
were you all nervous to watch yourselves
back on tv at all
yes yes yeah i definitely was i think
no i'm not happy with so i'm so excited
because this is really cool
it's really cool and it's like
professional people who like working for
a camera and like
so cute moving and like have like like
specific moment i love this this is so
cool
yeah that's my mistake i felt like i
looked so silly but
as you're thinking you look like city
right and you're not alone brandon i've
talked to a few 90-day couples and
everyone has
that feeling you know so it's it's not
unusual
right yeah yeah it's okay how have you
been feeling about
you know 90 day fans they are
opinionated so how have you been dealing
with the opinions so far
well they've definitely yeah they're
definitely very opinionated i mean
a lot of it uh some good you know a lot
of it
bad but yeah i mean i'm just
just taking the good really and just
trying to like tune out
bad stuff have your parents watch the
first episode yet
yes they have well was their reaction i
mean
they they thought it was great and
people seem to love them
that's the people really don't like me
brandon let's talk about your mom i know
she means
well but a lot of people have thoughts
when it comes to the birth control
conversation
including myself because it was a shock
how has she been dealing with the
criticism or how have you been dealing
with the criticism so far
um best i can really
i mean yeah i just really don't know
what to say about it i mean some of it i
might be even
agree you know speaking of children
you guys do not want children right away
right
what about you julia how do you feel
about the whole birth control
conversation now are your
your thoughts still the same um i mean
like i think
like if parents take care about birth
control
this is not parents business it's like i
guess like uh
mother mother not say like are you have
birth control like before i guess
like she like mother not asked this and
my mother not asked me this and like
i guess this is not like nice if like
mother-in-law
asked me like about boss control if
brandon don't care about this i don't
care about this so a lot of people have
mentioned um
that you know that's such a weird topic
to be even talking about with your
mother
yes it's like that's a hundred percent
true don't think it's anything
don't think that's it's any less weird
for me
no yeah and i think i mean
we know she means well because we get
why she's telling you
to do it you know but like you said it
seems like a boundary that was crossed
i have a question for you to tag on to
that brandon
why did you feel like it was necessary
to tell your parents you weren't using
protection
knowing that their reaction was not
going to be good and it was going to
make your situation worse it just kind
of
popped out i didn't really think about
it before i said it and
yeah the next thing i know is oh wait
why why did i even get into that
this is i don't want to be in this
conversation anymore but it's like too
late
julia how would you describe your
relationship with brandon's mom
i mean uh we have not bad relationship
we just have relationship
uh like mother-in-law and daughter
this is mean like this is not normal
we're not best friend
and we never be best friend if we leave
same farm
and because it's like not normal when
children live his parents
i mean like it's the same as my mother i
like i love my mother and i love bread
and mother
but if we live together
i i mean like explosion because this is
so hard so girl
same house never work never be friends
since brandon's super close relationship
with his parents
raised any concerns for you at all when
it comes to the future
i guess this is too much uh it's uh
close because
i i mean like i understand when people
like when child clothes parents
but not very close if you have something
like situation you not tell
everything what happened with your life
i mean like i not tell my parents
all my life if i tell parents all my
life my i guess my parents changed color
quickly
like gray and because it's like too much
stuff or parents don't eat no
yeah i wouldn't actually consider myself
that close to
my parents we have a great relationship
and
i mean i think she sees it that way
because you know we live together and
if like i i don't know you definitely
seem to think we're a lot closer and
you're the first one like say all that
but
i just don't feel that way i don't i
don't feel like we're
like it's like too close you know i just
feel like
i see them every day talk about stuff
yeah this is why but i'm not like
hey we're going to do this later do you
want to come with us like it's not like
that
this is like look like this and you you
answer like
what time you come back home what time
we leave where we go i mean
i think no i don't volunteer the
information i know
i know i'm being asked the information
constantly because there's constantly
like what are you doing where are you
going this kind of thing
so if i could answer um just i think my
mom is more attached
like to me than the other way around so
and that happens yeah i mean that
happens that you're not alone
in that a lot of people deal with that
as well but are we going to see this
this season are we going to see you
put any clear boundaries up when it
comes to your parents
is that going to happen um
it might it might have something yeah
just gotta watch and find out
well julia what was it about brandon
that made you want to marry him
after meeting him in person one time i
mean like
you look at him you just look at him
like he is so nice
and he it's like like so strange but
he'll not have like
something like bad inside i mean like
him
so nice and him so open for like
everything and
him understand me oh my god it's like if
you
really love me you stay with me this is
why
i love him but because not one person
stay with me if like we all not love me
yeah i also feel like you know even
though we had
like just a meeting we also had a ton of
time we were in each other's ear
all day every day talking 24 7 and so
we just you know i guess we meet but not
touch each other
yeah it was just that one part of our
relationship that we couldn't get and
it was other than that it was everything
else just learning about each other is
all we had and all we could do 24 7.
so we really really grew to know each
other well yeah well we can definitely
tell
i know there are some fans who are
skeptics and julia
what's your response to those who might
think that you're just with brandon for
a green card
what do you say to those fans
i can't stop repeating this uh this is
very interesting part and i won't answer
for people about
like i come here for green card i say i
you see
like first episode and now you'd sell
this i can't
you not see me but i already tell about
me if keep watching you see
it's like you're right or you're not
right so what are you basically saying
like we have to
the more we watch the more we will know
that you're not here for a green card
yeah that people have assumed that and
they haven't even like
seen her in the show i don't get here
yet so no maybe
i might just steal my green card
really says be nervous maybe she is all
right well let's talk about your living
situation julia
how are you adjusting to farm life how
is it
um my farm life for fantastic
this is dreams are you being sarcastic
i think she is julia you are funny
you have your jokes here and there i'm
like this girl has a great sense of
humor
you're more funny i am just little shy
no i'm not funny time he stuck himself
up every second
all right brandon you called julia dr
jekyll and mr hyde
can you explain to us exactly what you
meant by that
and for me too please
okay yes there were times when
we were going to like different
countries and going to meet each other
where she had displayed a different
personality
than when we had first met and
i mean it was just to me like little
things that would just
like set her off and she would just like
ruminate about it and i would i don't
know it was like sometimes she could be
an
absolute angel and then there's times
where she just
like yeah she just wouldn't she would
just
wouldn't stop she would be so angry
about something
welcome this is girl this is normal for
a girl
and men don't understand this okay we
have our we have our moves
what did you feel about his comments
julia when he called you dr jekyll
and mr hyde i mean like i have no idea
who he is
i explained to her yeah
exactly who the character and all that
like what that meant
it's like two persons who have like i
mean like yes this is true
i'm like just explosion and i say angel
but this
is plural this is not only me yeah
and you accept it randy you love her you
accept her for all of who she is
exactly exactly before i let you all go
are we gonna see it get to a point where
you have to choose between julia and
your parents
is that ever going to happen that's what
it kind of
seems like when you got my dad asking
like it
you know it's the farmer julia so
we'll see but you two are sitting here
right now so i think i have a clue
what your answer was or maybe you got
both
maybe you could have both who knows
look you are like
yeah i'm trying to be careful what i say
i totally understand
you